let's get some reaction to that
interview and the review uh we're joined
now by caroline noakes the chair of the
women and equalities committee at
westminster thank you for being with us
um we just heard there some of the
details of lady dorian's review into
making the
whole justice system easier for victims
of rape and serious sexual offences
would you like to see some of these
changes apply
throughout the uk well i think it's
important to reflect that scotland has a
separate
justice system but it's absolutely
crucial that we find
effective ways to support victims
through the criminal justice
system whether they be male or female
and
there have been good initiatives put in
place the independent sexual violence
advisors
who are supporting complainants through
the whole process and being with them
in court but i think there are some
really significant problems
about encouraging victims to come
forward making sure that police make
referrals to the cps
making sure that the cps has the
confidence to take things to trial that
we see
not just more convictions but more
prosecutions you won't get the
convictions
without the prosecutions in the first
place and i really
think it's time that the government look
closely at having a women's justice
strategy
so that we can see victims supported
from the
start to the end of the process yeah as
you say there are some clear
issues with the process not enough women
coming forward not enough referring to
the cps
and then if you look at the last three
years rape conviction is more than
halving
in england and wales i mean one of the
most controversial suggestions from lady
dorian is the fact that actually some of
these trials
should be heard not by juries who may be
vulnerable to
rape myths for example but by trained
judges i mean is that the kind of road
that we need to go down
if we're going to get serious about
getting convictions
well we have a long history and
principle
of crimes being tried by a jury of your
peers in this country
and i think that that is important but i
also think it's right that we have a
full and frank conversation about how we
can do things better how perhaps we can
do things quicker i thought
one of the most important points that
lady dorian made was about victims
having to relive their trauma
potentially
many times and over a long period and i
think
that we need to find a way that the
whole process can be speeded up
so that victims see cases coming to
court
much more quickly and then have the
opportunity to move on with the rest of
their lives
it does feel doesn't it that one of the
positive
things after a really grueling couple of
weeks for so many women has been
that we are starting to have a more full
and frank conversation about the kind of
harassment and the kind of assault as
well that some people face
and so many women do see as a fabric of
their lives you
recently gave an interview where you
said a labour mp tried to grape you
i mean talk about your own experience if
you want to obviously don't feel that
you have to
but how much of an issue do you think
this is for
for all women the kind of things that
we've been hearing
it's too common in every walk of life in
every um and this will be shocking
people here in every school playground
in every university in every workplace
this is going on far too often and when
you read the statistics about the number
of young women
that have been subject to sexual assault
or harassment
they're horrific and that's why i'm very
happy to co-sign amendments with people
like harriet harman
to make sexual harassment in a public
place uh outlawed
i think that that's really important we
have to change the culture
and that's why my committee has uh in
this last week launched
an inquiry into the cultures that are
underpinning
male violence against women i think it's
crucial that we
don't just um don't just pontificate on
this we need some practical solutions
and we need them quickly whether that be
through
the court system whether that's through
education whether we have a
candid conversation about pornography
the ease of access to it for young
people
and what that's doing to give them a
completely skewed
impression of what adult sexual
relationships are like
talking about changing the culture the
sunday mirror has a story this morning
about the culture within the police
and former police officers criticizing
sexism and
misogyny sir peter fahey who's the
former chief constable of quote in
manchester police said that if a member
of his family was attacked
he would probably advise him not to
report it he also said
there's no way his daughter would join
the police force
is there a problem of sexism in the
police
well i think that's a matter for the
police themselves to
investigate and look at um but reports
like that advising your children not to
join the police
not wanting to report crimes i think we
have a really important
job to do here empowering women who are
victims of crime
to go to the police to know that they
will be believed that they will have
their cases listened to sympathetically
i know here in hampshire police there
are more than 100 officers
working on this sort of crime and it's
treated with great sensitivity and
care but that's led by a female chief
constable who is absolutely committed to
doing that
i think it's absolutely vital that we
have to find
better ways to give women confidence and
when you look at the the statistics
around
sexual violence the statistics around
sexual harassment
unfortunately we're letting far too many
women down
okay thank you so much for coming on the
program this morning and caroline next
there thank you